church bells and panicked voices
ring out amid the destruction as people
in the small town of petrinia
rush to rescue people from the rubble
one house collapsed on top of this car
there's a man and a boy inside
thankfully local residents managed to
get them both out alive
but there have been deaths including a
12 year old girl
these pictures filmed by al jazeera may
clear the damage
houses completely collapsed others
partially destroyed
and stoneworks strewn across roads
al jazeera reporter marin versic was
reporting live when there was an
aftershock
were also affected by the quake
everything is destroyed all clothes are
inside there was a girl inside but
luckily she wasn't in the changing room
and she wanted to try some clothes i
don't know what to do now
i'm all shivering i feel like everything
is still shaking
soldiers from a nearby barracks were
quickly on site handing out blankets to
elderly people evacuated from a nursing
home
they've also brought emergency shelters
for the town's twenty thousand residents
dollars emergency services are coming
from zagreb
police civil protection services fire
brigades we have teams coming from other
parts of the country
we've mobilized everyone
we have to help people we have to give
them clothes and blankets
we have to make sure they have food we
must coordinate all teams and find a way
to get into the buildings
because as far as i'm concerned all
these buildings are dangerous now
some of the injured have been taken to
hospital in the capital zagreb 50
kilometers away
the epicenter of the 6.4 magnitude
earthquake was near here
just like a weaker quake on monday and
once again it could be felt in zagreb
where it damaged properties as well as
in neighbouring serbia
and bosnia while slovenia closed down
its only nuclear power plant just 100
kilometers from the epicentre as a
precaution
at this point i would like to underline
that even smaller magnitude earthquakes
are smaller than the mainstream that we
saw today might cause even more
significant damage
when they come closer to cities or they
become even more shallower
in march this year zagreb was hit by a
magnitude 5.3 quake that killed one
person
but this is a small town still reeling
and still trying to make sure everyone's
accounted for
nadine barber al jazeera